bei uns im studio ist bild vize paul
ronzheimer paul vitali klitschko der
bürgermeister von kiew ist nicht ganz
glücklich mit dieser geste er sagt 5000
helme sind ein absoluter witz was will
deutschland als nächstes zur
unterstützung schicken kopfkissen was
kommt als nächstes
das fragt er und vitali klitschko trifft
das gefühl in der ukraine denn die
menschen dort auf der straße können
nicht fassen wie wir mit ihnen umgehen
wie europa mit ihnen umgehen und ich
muss sagen wenn ich höre 5000 helme da
schäme ich mich für deutschland denn das
ist etwas was wirklich lächerlich ist
und wenn wir uns anschauen das dann
nicht verteidigungsministerin sich das
stolz auch noch hinstellt und sagt wir
stehen an der seite der ukraine wir
haben 5000 helme geschickt obwohl die
ukraine
hunderttausend brauchte so hört man aus
der ukraine
das ist wirklich eine schande ich schäme
mich dafür deutschland und wenn man in
diesem tag ich war ja über zehn tage
dort in der ukraine wenn man sich dort
mit den menschen und erhält dann ist das
image deutschlands wirklich im eimer die
sagen was ist denn bitte mit euch los
auf welcher seite steht ihr steht er auf
der seite des aggressors steht ihr auf
unserer seite was macht ihr da und 5000
helme die helfen natürlich gar nicht das
sind menschen dort die sich jetzt selbst
bewaffnen wenn man dort am wochenende
unterwegs ist einfacher hausfrauen
becker klempner die damit waffen üben
weil sie angst haben dass wladimir putin
einmarschieren könnte und unsere
verteidigungsministerin stellt sich dort
hin und sagt jawohl wir stehen an der
seite schicken 5000 helme das ist nur
noch lächeln also paul was wäre denn die
bessere unterstützung gewesen die
ukraine braucht defensivwaffen sie
brauchen panzerabwehrwaffen sie brauchen
das was zum beispiel großbritannien
geliefert hat also echte militärische
unterstützung zur abschreckung putins
die kosten für eine mögliche invasion
müssen so hochgehen dass wladimir putin
davon noch zurückschreckt und das ist
etwas wo ich denke deutschland helfen
sollte und diese argumentation die wir
da immer erlebt haben seit dem beginn
des ukraine krieg schon seit 2005 zehn
jahre da würde man putin irgendwie
provozieren das kann man nicht das wird
gefährlich wir sehen ja wo wir stehen
wir stehen in einer situation wo bleibt
mir mut jeden moment in die ukraine
einmarschieren könnte nur zwei stunden
flug von hier entfernt wo wir stehen
1200 kilometer luftlinie die hauptstadt
kiew der bürgermeister witali klitschko
hat sich auch die richtigen fragen
geäußert dass man eben defensivwaffen
das muss man ganz klar betonen also
verteidigungswaffen benötigen wir haben
mal rein
wie ist kein geheimnis
russische präsident sieht auch eine als
teil von
wiederaufbaus imperium wollen wir die
stellung in der vergangenheit wir sehen
uns in so gut in die europäische familie
das ist die grube denke ich mal wie sehr
doch um die was bekommen wir werden
darunter wir danken an alle partner
führung
politische unterstützung
aber wir brauchen auch unterstützung
brauchen waffen verteidigen nicht an 13
teiligen unseres wagens das ist sehr
wichtig ja und auch kolumnist der jan
fleischhauer der gathe kritik an dem
helm geschenk an die ukraine wir schauen
mal was er sagt also was muss
deutschland jetzt tun hat deutschland
eine historische pflicht zu helfen oder
gerade sich nicht einzumischen ja wie
hast du die wahrnehmung deutschlands in
der ukraine erlebt paul die ukraine
sagen wir statt
2014 mit europäischen flaggen am meiden
wir haben für europäische werte gekämpft
und warum unterstützt uns europa jetzt
nicht das ist wirklich etwas was die
menschen dort beschäftigt was die
menschen auf der straße diskutieren was
riesig dort in den medien ist an einem
wochenende als die ukraine waffen
geschickt hat nochmal zur verteidigung
waffen geschickt hat endete im internet
god save the queen und über deutschland
wird nun gespottet
gerade auch den nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg hier bei uns bei bild im
studio zum interview der von einer
echten kriegsgefahr sprach nun laufen ja
gerade gespräche zwischen den usa und
russland einerseits andererseits in dem
so genannten normandie format wurde
deutschland und frankreich zwischen
russland und der ukraine vermitteln
sollen also es wird diplomatie
wirklich im heißen modus geübt wie
schätzt du die chancen ein dass es
tatsächlich friedlich bleibt es ist ganz
schwer zu sagen und ich glaube die
experten die sagen ich weiß was putin
will lügen denn das weiß wahrscheinlich
nur putin selbst ich glaube die chancen
das ist eine friedliche lösung ohne
jegliche aggression gibt sind gering die
frage ist nur wie groß das wird da gibt
es unterschiedliche theorien die einen
sagen möglicherweise gibt es eine
provokation
in den so genannten separatisten
gebieten also in donetsk lugansk diese
gebiete an der russischen grenze oder
ein einmarsch in das komplette land und
das ist etwas glaube ich inzwischen sich
putin run entscheidet noch ganz kurz die
frage putin wir können ihm alle nur vor
die stärkung wir sehen mich in seinen
kopf rein du sagst ist es ganz kurz
davor es könnte wirklich jeden tag jede
stunde passieren welche sanktionen
könnten putin denn treffen eigentlich
also was können wir eigentlich noch tun
harte persönliche sanktionen für ihn für
sein umfeld dass die oligarchen
diejenigen die unterstützen auch nicht
mehr nach europa können mit ihnen privat
jets nach nizza auf die cote d'azur wo
auch immer ich glaube dass nord stream
auch ein entscheidender faktor sein kann
die wir bislang immer ausgeschlossen
haben also die gaspipeline man muss klar
machen dass wenn das passieren sollte
europa wirklich durchgreift und vor
allem dass europa geeint ist denn das
ist das problem auch das sharen länder
immer wieder aus und sagen andere dinge
als ein geeintes europa sagen sollte
einordnung von paul ronzheimer kinder